et la tragédie du vol à h 50 17 entraîne
dans son sillage de nombreux autres
drames 5 des 118 victimes étaient
québécoise et leurs proches peine à
trouver un sens à cette catastrophe
julie vaillancourt
depuis ce matin yaméogo bassirou et
réconfortés par les membres de la
communauté montréalaise burkinabé venus
le rencontrer à l'appartement d'un ami
on est des africains donc le fait devenu
le roi dont les discutant avec lui
d'échanger avec lui donc c'est déjà un
moyen de soutenir monsieur bassirou est
soudainement veuf sa femme et son fils
de 13 ans sont morts dans l'écrasement
du vol à h 50 17 sa famille venait le
rejoindre dans le cadre d'une demande de
parrainage on est arrivé c'est pour pour
leur donner le meilleure condition de
vie c'est surtout danser sans cesse et
voilà ils vont ils vont vivre jamais
voir le canada ils vont gérer voire
je vais jamais vous n'avez plus même les
rois c'est fou monsieur bassirou est
arrivé au canada en 2012 il vit
maintenant au saguenay il n'a pas revu
sa famille depuis son arrivée au pays
pendant vingt-neuf mois il aura
seulement parlé au téléphone
il recevra ce soir la visite de mamadou
zoungrana qui a perdu lui aussi sa femme
et ses deux enfants dans l'écrasement
d'avion le résidant de gatineau
s'envolera vers le burkina faso dans
l'espoir d'en apprendre davantage
monsieur bassirou lui préfère rester au
pays moi je sais pas ce que je vais
faire je vais aller dire quoi quand les
amorcé et des lambeaux de ça va je vous
préférez garder l'image que j'ai depuis
ça va peut-être
mais restait encore deux bons image que
de les voir des morceaux
de chair
à longueuil aussi une partie de la
communauté s'est déplacé afin de
réconforter rita somda la femme a perdu
son beau frère sa belle-soeur son neveu
et sa nièce et surtout wilfried le père
de son futur enfant non je peux prendre
l'avion fut trop court en seulement
grossesse ce n'est qu'après dans
quelques mois quand bébé sera à même de
prendre l'avion que je pourrais y aller
avec lui
difficile toutefois de faire son deuil
les proches des victimes ne savent
toujours pas quand ni comment ils
pourront dire adieu à ceux qui sont
décédés si tragiquement ici julie
vaillancourt a le canada montréal